yeah and dumb
literally gave me these exact chairs
i'm sorry to call him out i don't want
to call him out he's just fine i don't
want to call him just biting and
fighting no they're they're
blue but they're exact [ __ ] snake
[ __ ] you loved him at one point
he korean [ __ ] you loved him man wow you
loved him at one point earlier today
earlier today all right um dumbfounded
yeah tell him
i'm sorry dumb dumb i'm sorry
i know
i know that i'm more artistic than you
i know that my visual color stylings and
um well well i'll just say though
they're green and pink it it it's a
little better than ours
if i had thought of that
okay
well
what you what
what you're doing right now i what
you're doing right now i love green and
peach together it's a great combo that's
gonna be a tough one to it's a wrong
whatever you're doing right now is wrong
it's the wrong thing i don't know what
else to say to you it's the wrong thing
let me go back to dumb now dumb
you rat [ __ ] right i know that you're
the way you walk is like kind of like
mine oh oh yeah a little bit okay
if you look at if you look at him walk
his long if you close your eyes you
close
you close your eyes and your ears
no
but from afar if you see me and
dumbfounded walking
on a prairie
right from afar right you have
binoculars
all right imagine you two are well but
not you're a prairie you see me dumb
walking across right twisting your head
through the reeds
and you'd be in a waddle it's so cute
oh sweetie oh my gosh it's fun
it's fun
you just see the tip of this beanie
coming through the grass that's fun
that's fun stuff but i would see it
literally moving in the same silhouette
anyway
you stole that from me um secondly you
stole my the color design
of our podcast yeah right and now [ __ ]
face what you're doing
is you're looking at fur travel of ours
because you know it's good to furniture
you're going wow you know i mean but he
gave them to me he's not using them
that even hurts more
what you're saying to me gifting people
your style no what he's doing is he
orders stuff
right stuff that we have yeah he tries
it at home
and he looks at it and goes this is junk
right i'm gonna give this away to nora
is that what he's doing yeah that's
exactly what he did yeah exactly you
[ __ ] um korean rat
you're a korean rat dude and you know
what dude we'll work together but i
don't know man oh man yeah yeah you
[ __ ] up there's something that broke
yeah yeah
anyway um
you know wherever we go norah we take
ourselves with us yeah so now no matter
what is going on in your life
you think you can fantasize and go if i
made this money or if i did this or this
you know at the end of the day you
generally
feel the same oh totally i think i feel
sadder today than i ever have my whole
life why
i don't know she feels she's depressed
i'm super depressed right now yeah
it's more than that yeah you're going to
cry right now no i'm not going to cry i
don't know i want you to cry but i i go
through big like ups and down ups and
downs this is right on time i think
usually november is when it starts for
me do you find that it's oh so it's a
seasonal it can be i have a bipolar too
so my mania is not high but my
depression is real low oh no yeah yeah
i feel like my i i i
have like a cyclical aspect to my mood
that i'm starting to notice now like a
monthly
aspect to my mood yeah i feel like i go
between like really angry and like
like overconfident in like a not a lit
way yeah and and just like whatever like
and then and then like really fragile
too like whatever
and then to like actual fragile sad well
i call those days the angry and
confident and i call those um
um my sister and i call those the roni
days the testosterone days